Heidegger thought that Western
philosophy have gone wrong basically
since the time of Socrates which is you
know quite a long time and he said that
we were became interested in what the
world was made of and how we knew things
and what we should have been interested
instead was the nature and quality of
being and what he meant by being isn't
the objective world what he meant by
being was the manner in which you have
experience and so there are elements of
being that aren't objective elements and
so I would say pain is a
phenomenological reality right it's it's
not something you can you can index it
objectively but the index is not the
phenomenon and you know is your pain
real see this is this is a question for
people who think there's no such thing
as meaning like you try to argue
yourself out of pain and see how far you
get you might think well that's not the
sort of meaning I meant it's like you
know a negative meaning is a place to
start right because if something's
negative and it's real it does imply
that there's something positive that's
real it might be harder to get a hold of
at least it's not pain you know so but
pain Descartes then they'll close with
this you guys can have a break Descartes
implemented a method he called radical
doubt when he went on his philosophical
journey and what Descartes looked for
was one thing he couldn't doubt because
he was probably clinically depressed and
he was just doubting everything it's
like well why how do I know the world
isn't just a mirage made by an evil
demon to you know to to obfuscate
reality from me
well his conclusion was the one thing
that he could not dispute was that he
was and could think now I don't think
Descartes Reid meant what we meant by
think I think he meant more what we
would mean by experience because thought
has become a much more narrowly defined
I you know term since the time of
Descartes so I don't think he meant I
think therefore I am I think he meant
something like I experience I have
experienced therefore yeah but
regardless of that
people think about it as thought
Heidegger was different Heidegger
basically said the one thing you can't
dispute is that that experience is your
experience it exists you can't it's it's
almost by definition right it's like the
definition of exists and then he was
interested in what the fundamental
elements of existence of existence were
and they're not atoms like you know like
the fundamental elements of the object
of world there are more things like pain
and for me that was the thing that
stopped me from doubting it's like I
cannot doubt the existence of pain it
seems real and I might say it seems more
real than anything else now you might
say you don't believe that but I would
say I don't care what you think you
believe I'll watch you when you're in
pain and every single one of your
actions will indicate that you believe
in it and not only that that you can't
not believe in it right it's there and
it's there so much that well that's a
meaning and so that it's in that way
that Heidegger at least in part thought
of existence as or experience as
composed of meanings and so part of the
reason that this course is called nobs
of meaning is because one of the things
we're going to look at is the structure
of meaning and we're gonna start with
negative meaning because from my
perspective it's look you can doubt
whether or not good exists but once I'm
done telling you about the things I know
about human history there won't be a
single person in this room who thinks
that evil doesn't exist and you might
think that's a bloody horrible thing to
learn but it's not it's unbelievably
useful because once you can establish
something that you cannot deny then you
can move from that and I think you can
hypothesize that if you're capable of
detecting radical evil I'll tell you
about unit 731 at some point or you can
look them up yourself I wouldn't
recommend it by the way once you can
identify radical evil and you think well
that's that's just rep beyond a doubt
that's reprehensible there's no
justification for that whatsoever no
matter what whenever well then you've
got something to stand
and you can start thinking well what's
the absolute opposite of that then you
know it might be how is it that you
could conduct yourself so that in your
sphere of influence the probability like
that anything like that would ever
happen is reduced to the absolute
maximum well that's a reasonable moral
question
and I and I don't think it's something
that you can dispense with with like a
casual nihilism I don't think a nihilist
can dispense with it because he even
nihilists suffer thank God for that you
know it's their only uh it's their only
source of potential salvation sometimes
they notice it oh I'm suffering about
all this nihilism
maybe that indicates that there's
something flawed in it it's always
possible